okay let me have it what did you come up
with expert systems / experts what do
you lose what kind of problems do you
end up having yeah emotionless
okay give me an example why that's
important because I think we said before
that the emotionless this led to
consistency right it's always the same
thing which could be a plus so why could
it be a negative can't give me an
example okay so when when these
decisions affect people okay yeah they
can be problems that come in there if
something's like a system is not
sensitive to those kinds of issues can
you give me an actual concrete example
okay yeah all right so there's a there's
a sort of awareness that humans have of
human beings how they feel and how
they've been affected by situation which
not just affects each individual
decision but also how they relate to
each other all right that's fine okay
because I will give you a totally
separate issue problem weakness
disadvantage hmm okay so I'm trying to
think about that's true so we're talking
about you know the hardware limitations
on the system I'm trying to I'm trying
to steer away from the general ones
right because we can always say things
like you need you need electricity and
you need all these kinds of things which
are gonna apply to every piece of
technology and we can list them off
that's fine but I want to can we be more
specific about how to face decisions
okay did anyone have one it's a little
more related up the back anyone any
takers
okay alright so the job theory the
employment situation I'm not going to
put that under here okay for two reasons
even though it's actually valid it's a
very important issue together okay
employment as you saw you may remember
really did multimedia right he's always
been a two-edged sword with technology
because you destroy jobs and
simultaneously you create create them
right so depending on what kind of
technology sometimes you end up gaining
more jobs than you lose or vice versa
okay however the real reason I'm not
including under here is that I'm trying
to get at the the way the decision
support system functions and does its
job like how does it not not the social
impacts outside I'm like walking in this
situation what is better and what is
worse does that make sense
okay now just keep my eye on the time
Rocco's gonna come soon so I'm just
gonna zip through that's okay I've got
I've got four reasons okay so number one
it can be done here's what I mean by
that okay excuse me
common sense and intuition right are
characteristically human sort of
qualities right you're like look this is
obviously confiture okay they they
clearly convey that this wouldn't make
any sense now for a computer that kind
of thing is actually very difficult to
program common sense right so you say
Dom right computers make completely
ridiculous decisions just think of the
last time GPS told you okay if you want
to get from A to B the best way to do it
this go some crazy other way okay and
then you'll land there half an hour
later okay it's just following the rules
that it knows to provide you with
assistance in making your decision and
doesn't see in a common sense of well
just because there's no you know part of
the map that shows you go from here to
here directly it doesn't mean you can't
right so common sense is something that
it's very difficult to program into a
system secondly this is the sort of flip
side of the consistency thing right
expert it's one of the great things
about that is that often they are marked
by creativity right they can come up
with a new kind of solution for an old
problem or being a new problem that they
never met before and through all of
their accumulated wisdom and experience
they'd be like okay I can work and what
to do here
now an expert system by contrast usually
is my fun fact that it'll keep doing the
same thing every time very predictable
right this is one of the challenges in
producing a system that could beat a
chess master right because if you play
game after game after game it'll keep on
doing very similar things if you provide
it with the same inputs okay that's
great for consistency it's bad if what
you need is actually something novel
something new something creative okay
all right thirdly um data integrity
now what's that integrity do you know it
has to do with reliability right it
includes two things number one accuracy
okay the data that you have has to be
right and number two remember what was
the difference what's the distinguishing
between accuracy and integrity that's
still that's still part of accuracy yeah
yeah you mentioned that reliability I
think I heard it yeah you've got to have
everything okay so the diversity
integrity and accuracy is not just is it
right what you've got but you've got to
have the whole picture okay so you know
the array will you remember it is uh in
in court people say I swear to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth right that's not integrity now
why is that a promise for expert systems
okay well the the pool of knowledge and
expert system is is is getting out right
it's going to be fixed okay it needs to
be updated manually so a crucial feature
about an expert system is that of itself
it doesn't learn okay so dial integrity
is a big problem for that because the
world that we live in is constantly
changing right so it's gonna be updated
manually by subset of programmers and
some other experts in the domain who
actually know this stuff and they see
how the situation is changing their data
integrity is gonna go out the window
very quickly okay not only will things
change in the situation okay but also
there will be new things discovered
which the echo system doesn't know
looking whereas humans learning is part
of what makes us feel it right so an
extra system very important this is a
distinction between this and the next
kind of level artificial neural networks
we classify both of these as artificial
intelligence but expert systems they
don't learn that a change unless you do
it yourself whereas an artificial neural
network the cool thing about it is it
learns on its own we'll get to that
later ok ah one last reason one last
disengage it has to do again with this
arm not learning ok
we have a rule in to your expert system
ok and it learns to make these decisions
but what if the decisions turned out
really bad ok you do you make this kind
of choice
I get it again and again and it's it's
obvious that you know you get very very
poor outcomes ok if it's gonna be
consistent like an expert system is it's
gonna keep on doing it again and again
again right it won't respond to its
stimuli ok when it when it makes a
decision and it turns out bad it's not
gonna change like a human would okay how
many times do you have to press
something you get zapped Eli okay I'm
gonna stop doing that now right where is
the expert systems just gonna keep on
going after a particular line of action
a particular series of logic even if it
turns out badly okay I suppose you could
call it unresponsive